julian jw it's come down to france and
the united states in our first ever
international competition now we're
sending you back to your home for just
to recreate an iconic weapon from
history are you ready to see what it is
uh already well that weapon is
the spadrone
all right bladesmiths good luck we'll
see you in five days
i'm happy to be home in san francisco in
france look
at the nice view behind us
it's magnificent so i start to make my
tip but i have to be really fast because
the more you hit your blade less carbon
you have
it's like music for second music i love
to do some music with my hammer
just get you some rhythm it's just more
fun
[Music]
today i did it all the time the tip the
blade all i have left is to grind it a
little bit and it's going very well
i'm excited to get started this morning
fixing to start profiling everything so
we'll spend a bunch of time with the
grinder today
well the length of this blade i mean
it's like grinding three 10 inch buoy
knives you've got a ton of work
just getting everything rough ground out
we're just about ready to go to heat
treat on it right now would be time for
a little prayer
now the grinding process was slower than
i would have liked for it to be so this
is a short amount of time left to a heat
treat
i notice this curve from the top down
and his heart sinks i've got to do
something to correct this
i know i can't fix it cold so we got to
go back into heat treat again
i take it out of the oil and i got the
same thing i'm thinking i'm going to
have to regroup and start over
so today i'm gonna work to be ready for
the crunch the crunch is important
because if the quench is not good my
blade's gonna be like butter and she's
gonna bend at the first shot
[Music]
i think it bends
i know that there's a weak point on my
blade will make the curve
so i have to do second one
boom
third crunch this one goes down i don't
want to do another one
[Music]
you have to make a another blade i have
to restart everything
i don't want to do another blade but
i've got my country behind me so i have
to show them that i respect them and
give the best yeah
i thought about a lot what happened
yesterday i've got plenty to work with
but i still got a slight curve in the
spine so what i'm going to have to do is
grind that away
going good
as i'm grinding i can tell that this
thing's gonna be okay what a huge relief
that is
and now that this blade issue is fixed i
can focus on fit and finish what's
challenging about it is hitting the
sizing right on it instead of having a
round handle we're going to have an oval
handle there's just nothing comfortable
about a round handle when you're
striking something on an angle done deal
i've got real high expectations of it i
really do i think it's going to do well
blaze bits to find out how lethal your
weapons are i will deliver some slashes
and thrust on these big carcasses until
the end you're up first you ready i
think so
right julian let's talk about your sword
here
it's a bit on the heavier side
your edge easily
lacerates into the big carcass on a
thrust it penetrates deep your weapon
definitely is sharp your sword will kill
thank you
jw you're next you ready
[Music]
okay jw
let's talk about your spidoon here the
fact that you put the fuller all the way
through up here lightened your sword a
lot it is so sharp
almost cut all the way through this
carcass
overall
your weapon will kill
thank you doug
now donald mcbain who wrote the book on
this weapon called it the shearing sword
so to test the sharpness of your blades
i'll be chopping through this rope and
then attacking these sandbags as they
fall julian you're up are you ready we
okay
i'll give him
[Music]
yes
it's good
it's freaking good
well julian
that's sharp
it passed right through the ropes it
passed right through the bags but the
weight in this sword and the shape of
its handle just have a tendency to be
very hard to to stop
a little thinner handle possibly a
little more indexed yeah would have
helped but it's definitely a sharp sword
thank you very much
sir
you are next are you ready yes sir
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
definitely sharp enough to cut through
the ropes your handle would have been
nice to see it taper and swell a little
bit more but it's definitely a cutter
thank you all right nicely done
all right gentlemen next up is the
strength test now to test the strength
and durability of your blades i'll be
thrusting with the tip and cutting into
these hardwood leather wrapped shields
jw you ready for this yes sir
[Music]
well everything on the blade looks good
guard's still tight handle hasn't moved
think you did a great job thank you dave
julian
are you ready
good luck
[Music]
so julian you got a very stout edge
profile blade's still straight well done
thank you so much
well gentlemen the judges have made
their decision
our very first forged and fire
international champion is jw
congratulations you are our first forged
and fired international champion
julian we
unfortunately your blade did not make
the cut
jay nielsen will explain
julian you brought us a beautiful piece
compared to your competitor your blade
was a lot heavier in the front balance
wise and with that round handle it made
a lot harder controlling the testing
that's why we're going to let you go
julian
say for me mona me please surrender your
weapon
okay
thank you guys i'm very proud of this
blade but
jw is a god he is a god in a forge
and
this guy is my friend
jw the american and our very first
forged and fired international champion
it's a title that also comes with a
check for ten thousand dollars
congratulations please present your
weapon to the judges
i put
forth a lot of hard work time and effort
to reach this point so it's just been an
incredible honor
to be asked to represent my country and
not only that but being able to meet
guys from different parts of the world
and the friendships that we developed
was just a great experience and that's
what it's all about
[Music]
you